[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kylie jenner and travis scott's baby
girl
just turned three years old and in true
kylie travis fashion
they went all out we are just doing a
cousin party
with all her cousins and my family which
will be
still just as amazing um but yeah i
can't wait to show you guys
the proud mama hit up her insta story on
monday to share some snaps of little
stormies third times a charm themed
birthday bash
which included a table set for tiny
royalty with
lots of balloons a giant inflatable
slide
that resembled stormy's face a wall
lined with
candy and sweets galore a princess
carriage made
entirely of balloons the raisin canes
truck
serving up chicken fingers grilled
cheese and french fries
custom-made hoodies more balloons oh
did i mention the balloons
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the birthday girl looked every bit the
regal b-day princess in a tiny pink gown
and tiara
and couldn't have been cuter while
ordering a treat at her bash
her polite manners always on point
[Music]
i would love one i love watermelon too
no thank you oh cute i love it
of course it wouldn't be a kardashian
birthday without a
whole lot of instagram tributes stormy's
aunties kendall chloe and courtney all
shared sweet snaps of the b-day girl
while kim shared this pic of the cousins
that's rob's daughter dream stormy kim's
little girl chicago
and chloe's daughter true i loved it
stormy's grandma kris
jenner posted this photo and gushed over
how stormy is so smart and funny and
sweet
such a blessing storm's rapper dad
travis scott
penned an epic poem with lots of cute
rhymes like
three is bigger than two three more
years of love that's true
three more inches you might have grew
three more years a lot to do
three more times i love you and
cue the tears yeah and kylie's crying
too
she brought all the feels writing in
part quote
watching you experience everything for
the very first time has been the best
part of these last few years
but on the other side i'm excited to
watch you grow into the most special
girl i know you will be
and all the amazing things i know you
will do happy birthday to my baby
forever
you